so i have two different expressions here
that i want to take the derivative of
and what i want you to do is pause the
video and think about how you would
first approach taking the derivative of
this expression and how that might be
the same or different as your approach
in taking the derivative of this
expression the goal here isn't to
compute the derivatives all the way but
really to just think about how we
identify what strategies to use
okay so let's first tackle this one and
the key when looking at a complex
expression like either of these is to
look at the big picture structure of the
expression so one way to think about is
let's look at the outside rather than
the inside details
so if we look at the outside here we
have the sign
of something
so there's a sign of something going on
here that i'm going to circle in red or
in this pink color so that's my how my
brain thinks about it from the outside
i'm like okay big picture i'm taking the
sine of some stuff i might be taking
some stuff to some exponent in this case
i'm inputting it a trigonometric
expression but if you have a situation
like that it's a good sign that the
chain rule is in order
so let me write that down so we would
want to use in this case
the chain rule cr for chain rule
and how would we apply it well we would
take the derivative of the outside with
respect to this inside
times the derivative of this inside with
respect to x and i'm going to write it
the way that my brain sometimes thinks
about it
so we can write this as
the derivative
with respect to
that something i'm just going to make
that that pink circle for the something
rather than writing it all again
of
sine of
that something
sine of that something not even thinking
about what that something is just yet
times
times the derivative with respect to x
of that something
this is just an application of the chain
rule no matter what was here in this
pink colored circle it might have been
something with square roots and
logarithms and whatever else as long as
it's being contained within the sign i
would move to this step the derivative
with respect to that something of sine
of that something times the derivative
with respect to x of the something
now what would that be tangibly in this
case
well
this first part
i will do it in orange
this first part would just be
cosine
of
x squared plus 5 times cosine
of x
so that's that circle right over there
let me close the cosine
right over there and then times the
derivative with respect to x
times the derivative with respect to x
of all of this again of x squared plus 5
times cosine
of x
and then i would close my brackets and
of course i wouldn't be done yet i have
more derivative taking to do
here
now i would look at the big structure of
what's going on
and i have two expressions being
multiplied i don't have just one big
expression that's being an input into
like a sine function or cosine function
or one big expression that's taken to
some exponent i have two expressions
being multiplied i have this
being multiplied
by
this
and so if i'm just multiplying two
expressions that's a pretty good clue
that to compute this part i would then
use
the product rule and i could keep doing
that and compute it i encourage you to
do so but this is more about the
strategies and how do you recognize them
but now let's go to the other example
well this looks a lot more like this
step of the first problem than the
beginning of the original problem
here i don't have a sign of a bunch of
stuff or a bunch of stuff being raised
to one exponent
here i have the product of two
expressions just like we saw over here
we have
this expression
being multiplied by this expression so
my brain just says okay i have two
expressions then i'm going to use the
product rule two expressions being
multiplied i'm going to use the product
rule if it was one expression being
divided by another expression then i
would use the quotient rule but in this
case it's going to be the product rule
and so that tells me that this is going
to be the derivative
with respect to x
of
of the first expression just going to do
that with the orange circle
times the second expression i'm going to
do that with the blue circle
plus the first expression not taking its
derivative
the first expression times
the derivative with respect to x of
of
the second expression
once again here this is just the product
rule you can substitute sine of x
squared plus 5 where you see this orange
circle and you can substitute cosine of
x where you see this blue circle but the
whole point here isn't to actually solve
this or compute this but really to just
show how you identify the structures in
these expressions to think about well do
i use the chain rule first and then use
the product rule here or in this case do
i use the product rule first and even
once you do this you're not going to be
done then to compute this derivative
you're going to have to use the chain
rule and you'll keep going until you
don't have any more derivatives to take